hello everybody thanks for coming so
early in the morning to come and watch
my talk so today I'm gonna talk about
packed arrays and then I'm going to talk
about a generalization of packed arrays
that we've been working on called
numeric arrays does everybody know what
a packed arrays or so a packed array
since started life in the old compiler
as a data structure as it should be on
I'll reboot it
yeah that better so so packed arrays
were added to the colonel they started
life inside the compiler when we added
arrays of functions and then they were
added to the kernel as a as a genuine
expression a wrapper for the data
structure they have three basic types
from machine integer that's the largest
signed machine integer on the machine a
machine real a 64-bit floating-point
number or a machine complex which is a
pair of real 64-bit numbers they match
the native machine types in Mathematica
and the functionalities was refined
after the release over successive
versions so what's the difference packed
arrays are practically indistinguishable
from lists many functions generate
packed arrays automatically so here's an
example here this this function range
notice that it's working with machine
numbers it makes this thing here and
then I type in manually this list of
numbers and I get this thing here this
is the list and this is actually a
packed array and you can use this
special function to distinguish between
the two so packed array essentially lays
out all the data as a machine array
consecutively whereas a list has a
Mathematica data structure wrapped
around each each number okay so you can
see here you have better data locality
but here you have more generality
because these things can live and they
can mix with symbols and they can mix
with with rational numbers and all the
other types of expressions that we have
in Mathematica and another advantage is
that packed arrays because they use
consecutive machine registers
they use less memory okay so the
advantages of a packed array well I put
this down also as a disadvantage that
they're indistinguishable from this you
you often don't know if you're working
with a packed array or not and that
could be a bit frustrating it can be
difficult to track when operations are
packed and unpacked off when we take a
list of mathematical lists and we
automatically
back it to a packed array do some
computation to make it more efficient
and then unpack it back to a list and
it's often difficult for a user to know
when that sort of thing is going on and
the other thing is that in order for
them to coax it coexists seamlessly with
the system we switch in and out of
packed arrays so here's an example where
I make a packed array containing the
continum maximum machine number ok this
confirms it's a packed array then I
multiply it by 2 and exceptions
generated that that number can no longer
fit as a machine real number and
mathematical switches to arbitrary
precision to compute this result okay so
I've switched out of the realm off of a
machine array into the realm of a list
and all that stuff has gone on behind
the scenes so it makes it a good Center
system integration but it makes for a
non constant running time because
obviously this arbitrary precision
computation is much much slower and the
machine precision cut the computation so
what's the numeric array a numeric
arrays is a generalization of packed
array so we no longer have the
restriction of using the largest machine
precision types we have 8 16 32 and 64
bits signed and unsigned integers real
32 which is a float or real 64 which is
a double and the complex equivalents of
those so the obviously obvious benefits
are memory and speed which is useful in
the gnu compiler audio/video processing
or machine or machine learning but this
generalization two types brings with it
its own set of issues that I'll go into
a little bit later so here's how to make
a numeric array here's my list of three
numbers I call a numeric array and I
give it the type of the thing that I
want to compress down to okay this then
makes a machine array where each of
these is represented as a signed 8-bit
integer okay and this is the predicate
that can be used to test that that is
actually a numeric array and then I can
convert from one numeric array type to
another so this converts this this
integer eight format into a real 32
floating-point number so I just specify
my numeric array that I've made up here
I give it as argument to a numeric array
and I specify the target type and I get
this new numeric array with the real 32
type instead of the integer 8 type I can
unpack them in a sense convert them back
to a list okay by using normal now
normal what we'll try to do is it will
try to make a pact array the largest
machine type machine array type that can
be used to represent it if it can
otherwise it will unpack it to a list
okay and this conversion is now in
parallel so if I if I call it range say
with you know 10 to the power of 8
element this makes a packed array and
then I convert that to a floating point
to set floating point values then you
can see that that's this this function n
on a packed array now works in parallel
so this is the time to convert that from
an integer array to a floating point
array this is the serial timing and this
is the parallel timing so I can create
the America race with identical values
but different types so here I create a
numeric array which has an integer a
type with the values 1 2 3 and here it
has unsigned integer 32 type if I use
same queue then because these types are
different these are considered to be
different if I use equal equal is value
based and so equal will go through these
values even though they're different
types and compare them ok so this is the
2 2 ways of distinguishing between them
so most of the stuff I'm going to talk
about is going on in the Wolfram runtime
library here which is a separate
component from Mathematica but used by
Mathematica it's used in the new
compiler by the kernel by the old
compiler when you make standalone code
library link and in the future possibly
the front end and and maybe even the
number theory library which Charles is
talk about tomorrow I believe so the
good thing about this is we can use a
separate code base so that all
- run time might be written in C++
modern C++ which the kernel is not so we
can start with a modern home base code
base and do things much more efficiently
on a smaller subset of code so that's my
memory allocator in the Wolfram runtime
like this four times faster than malloc
because it uses I was paid to how it
distributes memory and carves up memory
and stuff like that that makes it faster
than malloc which is a general allocator
so the we we need to make a few changes
to the system in order to make these
things integrate better and also for the
compiler to have a better mapping from
Mathematica to say native C code so one
of the things we did in version 11 point
3 was to change underflow and overflow
of machine numbers machine underflow is
no longer detected and trapped so that
we can use subnormal not numbers from
the I Triple E standard now we've made
another change where there was one
single value in Mathematica this - - -
the 63 that was not a machine number
whereas in C is a machine number
okay so C represents signed numbers in a
slightly asymmetric way the largest
machine number that can be represented
is - 263 - 1 and the smallest the
largest negative number is -2 to the 63
this was always not allowed to be a
machine number in Mathematica before and
this means if we wanted to write out
data or read in data we'd always have to
check for this one specifically value
but now it now each made changes to
allow for this value the problem is if
you do this in C if you take this number
and you negate it you'll still get
another negative number so the negation
of a negative number is negative which
kind of breaks the mathematical laws and
obviously that we don't want to do that
in Mathematica so if you negate this
number in Mathematica instead of being
machine number machine integer it will
be a big integer ok so that we can
continue to support you know
sort of predicates and things like that
but it does mean that we can read and
write I raise the Machine numbers of
specific types into 64 integer 32 etc
but without having any additional checks
of things that's just as just showing
you if I negate this number it was a
machine number but the positive version
is it's not machine number so one change
that we've made is to sorting so
mathematically as always ease merge sort
as it's basic sorting algorithm since
the very beginning never really
implemented any other any other thing
that the reason is Mosul is a stable
sort I'll explain what that means in a
minute it has a bounded sub-quadratic
worst case complexity it has a linear
complexity for sorted arrays so
mathematics infinity evaluation so if
something was sorted and we want to sort
it again then it's just linear linear
time to scan through that instead of
being n log n or ever and merge sort
uses fewer comparisons than quicksort
which is good if we're comparing
expressions expressions are quite big
and the ordering function that's used to
sort stuff can be quite expensive so we
want to keep the number of comparisons
smaller so here's an example here I'm
asking what the ordering is of this data
and if I use a packed array this is what
I get so I have several ones in this
thing the one that comes first should be
first in my list of ordering that's what
the stable sort means the one that comes
second should remain second and the one
that comes third remains third and then
the other two values come in here and
the same thing identical results if I
use a list instead of a packed array and
that's because factories are supposed to
be seamlessly integrated you're not
supposed to get a different result
if use a packed array compared to a list
expression
so sorting a continuous machine array
impact oral numeric array doesn't really
have the same kind of stability
restriction that we do when we're
working with a generic list so if I'm
asking for the order in which things
come in it has to be the same as the
list but if I'm just want to sort this
data okay here's my example from before
it doesn't really matter if this one
comes in the first position the second
position or the third position is just a
one in the machine array so so this one
doesn't necessarily need to come first
it doesn't really need to be a stable
sort anymore okay because I'm just
sorting this this array of data so that
means that we can now use alternative
sorting methods we use a quicksort
method now which is much more efficient
for a contiguous arrays because it has
better data locality and the other thing
is that the parallel implementations of
sorting and becoming much more widely
available
so here's yeah yes because they have
zero tolerance yeah so here's an example
so I'll make a floating-point numbers
for you at I in Reverse I'll make a
reverse ordered list asking for a large
one down to a small one and then I'll
sort this data so here is the new
sorting function using quicksort and
here it is working in parallel and here
is the the same sort well or ordering
instead of sorting this has to use merge
sort because it has to match the list
form okay and you can see that the merge
sort this is the serial merge sort and
this is the parallel merge sort
okay so we've gone down from this which
is the previous version of Mathematica
down to this in the parallel version of
the the quicksort which is an order of
magnitude faster
so a little bit about paralyzation how
does paralyzation work in the runtime
library we essentially carve up a vector
of all this array of machine integers
into blocks okay and these blocks are
chosen according to the data locality of
the cache of the processor and according
to the cost of the operations that were
performing like some operations might be
more expensive than others so we want to
tune tune this block size of how we
carve this up so here with a parallel
functions that have been implemented in
the runtime library quite a few of them
so any anything that's a constructor
constant or a range multiple part of
Simon take drop flatten and array
reshape of course the numeric array the
constructor and two packed array the new
thing that we have a couple of weeks old
now is all arithmetic now works on these
numeric arrays so I can add them I can
subtract them I can use bit operations I
can do all sorts of things with those so
we have 78 unary operations 21 binary
and 5 ternary that we don't yet have an
interface for they used in linear
algebra and we also have map reduction
things like total max min max max abs
etc the other thing that we have is
comparison of packed arrays or numeric
arrays now works in parallel to so
things like sane queue or equal if
you're comparing very large arrays of
machine numbers that works in parallel
as well so here's an example of same
queue with two packed arrays which is
the same and you can see it working more
efficiently in parallel and also this is
the this is in a sense the worst case
for comparison because these are
absolutely identical if I make the first
element different in one of these two
then I want to make sure that my
parallel version is not much slower than
my serial version and that shows that
it's within a factor of two
the parallel version compared to the
serial
so I just want to talk a tiny bit about
transposition so transpose has also been
implemented in the run time might be now
instead of the kernel and it's actually
quite a complicated problem it's not
actually part of la pack the linear
algebra library and there are lots and
lots of cases to consider so I'll just
look at two of them out of place
transpose and and this in place
transpose often we want to transpose
something in place because of the memory
restrictions it's a very large array
very large matrix like sometimes they
turn up in complex fast Fourier
transforms and we don't want to make a
physical copy of that that object we
want to actually transpose it in place
and that's actually much much harder
open open problem to do that
so matrix transpose if I'm prepared to
make a copy for the result of the
transposition
then then things are pretty
straightforward the only thing that we
have now is that we do this in blocks
for a better data locality and then
these blocks can be evaluated in
parallel so the new version of transpose
the serial version is about 20% faster
than version 12 but it also works in
parallel you can see here this is the
time to transpose a 10,000 by 10,000
matrix now when it's in place the
algorithm to work in place is slightly
more complicated it's a cycle based
algorithm in the length of the cycles of
things that are moved around depends on
the dimensions of the matrix so here's
an example of three by five matrix five
by three and I'm going to transpose it
here so there are three cycles that
don't values that don't move and those
are the ones that are going to be sort
of on the diagonal in the results so the
element 0 7 and 14 stay where they are
in the results they don't move around
and so the position in the result is the
same as the position in the thing it
started out as and there are two other
cycles 1 3 9 the
11:5 so what I need to do is I need to
swap 1 & 3 3 goes up to where one is it
becomes orange and then I need to swap 1
& 9 1 goes into place of 9 & 9 goes in
the place of 1 9 is now in the right
position then I need to go and swap 1
and 13 13 goes down here then I need to
swap these two and then find out what
those two and all the ones in orange and
now in the right place in the transpose
and then I go through another cycle and
do exactly the same thing swap 2 & 6 and
then swap 2 and 12 etc etc etc and I end
up with this ok and this if I just
reshape it just changing the dimensions
ok
this is the transposed result of the
original thing that we we started in
this ok so but you might notice one
thing about this this data movement is
all over the place I mean these cycles
they have this kind of rather arbitrary
pattern and that's not good for data
locality and it's also impossible to
paralyze so this is a good basic
algorithm quite easy to implement but
not good for data locality for large
matrices and not good for paralyzation
elegant simple to me implement doesn't
use the cache efficiently and it's
inherently sequential so we've
implemented a new algorithm which which
does work in parallel and does have data
locality so it's a recent paper from
four years ago there's only two
implementations I'm aware of and the
idea is to consider this as a this
matrix as a 2d array instead of a 1d
array so before we had these cycles that
worked in one dimension okay but now now
we do operations that work in two
dimensions so here's my example of a
four by eight matrix the GCD of 8 and 4
is 2 so the first thing I'm going to do
because the GCD isn't is not one is I'm
going to need to do a like a
pre-processing step that's this column
rotation and I'm going to move things
around in columns in blocks of 2 so 24
28 that was here it's going to go down
here and 16 and 20 is going to go here
eight and twelve gonna go here then once
I've done that and this is only done
when the GCD is is not one then I'm
going to shuffle stuff within each row
okay so seven that was here goes to the
end three that was here goes here etc
etc so I'm ordering stuff within each
row and then once I've done that I'm
gonna order staff within each column so
here and here and here and here and here
and here so you can see about this it
has very good data locality because all
the operations are working only on
single rows and on single columns and
also they're working in a completely
independent fashion so they can be
paralyzed or had a timing chart here
anyway so then we've made some other up
to optimization to this to this
arithmetic to this to this in place
transposition that got us a factor of
four speed-up essentially we don't want
the algorithm rolls expensive modular
arithmetic on every single index
computation we don't want to do that
modular division etc is quite expensive
like division of integers on on a CPU so
we've take take make use of the fact
that we're working on the grid and we do
only one expensive computation and just
move to the neighbors using a cheaper
arithmetic system
okay so we've worked out in Mathematica
and we've managed to get this algorithm
to work four times faster than was
previously implemented so now with
within a factor of two of the the out of
place transposition which is about as
good as things can get so lastly with
the time I've got left I'd like to talk
about arithmetic since I worked hard to
squeeze it into this talk so I think
Todd Galen yesterday said this isn't
available generally it's only in his
version so this is only in my version
and is completely a work in progress now
the arithmetic is fully implemented in
runtime library the question is how do
we expose it to the user okay and we
have several choices and I'll try and
explain to you a little bit about what
those choices are and why we're leaving
one way instead of another but just to
show you that it works here what I've
done is I've made a vector of
floating-point numbers this this is
double precision it's a packed array
here and I've gone in evaluated the
square root function it both in serial
and in parallel then I've now made an
array of floating-point numbers so I've
taken this array of double precision
numbers and I've used the numeric array
to compact them down to 32-bit floats
instead of the 64-bit floats so the
single precision instead of double
precision and you can see that the
memory is cut by half and this is a
comparison of the timing to evaluate the
square root function and you can see in
serial it's about two and a half times
its last in parallel it's about twice as
fast so working with single precision
numbers if it was square roots if I'm
not so interested in the akka is
something I can compact it down to a
float I get a factor of two gain in
memory and a factor of two gaining speed
so what's the problem the problem is
when we have mixed types and we're using
binary operation say we want to do plus
but we're doing plus of an unsigned
integer eight and an integer eight so
the types aren't compatible okay okay if
we start to do that allowing that kind
of thing then we're going to have a
proliferation of the number of routines
that we have we're going to have we have
twelve types if we allow each Cross of
those types in in binary arithmetic
we're now a hundred and forty-four cases
of plus x divide it say then if we allow
that for ternary it's going to be one
thousand odd routines every single time
so it I actually tried that in the
runtime library allowed every cross type
and the compiler crash it wasn't even
able to compile the thing ran out of
memory and crashed and I had 32
gigabytes and and also when I did get it
to succeed on a bigger machine but the
runtime library binary became bigger
than the kernel binary which is not not
really what the sort of thing that we
want so we really have to make some
choices and restrictions about the sort
of thing that we want to do here so do
we really want to support the arithmetic
in the kernel this is the question so
here a couple of examples comparing the
kernel arithmetic to the compiler
arithmetic so if I take a numeric array
that has a definite type and I use part
in it inside the kernel where the only
thing the kernel can do is make it what
it knows is an integer out of that thing
we don't have a representation of types
numbers in the kernel so I've lost this
information I'm taking out this one here
but this one was an integer eight type
I've extracted it from a vector and I've
made the scalar one which is a machine
integer okay just two minutes and an oh
yeah so which is a machine integer so
I've lost this type of information okay
so that's a problem with doing things in
Mathematica all we introduced type
numbers every single type we have a a
one that's an integer eight time for one
that's an integer 16 type and we have a
proliferation of things
all we do it through the compiler
because the compiler when it has a type
system nobody knows about numbers of
different types and it already knows
about a lot of the infrastructure that
we're going to need to do those kinds of
things here's another example I have T
numeric arrays and I want to subtract
them so I write any one
they're both unsigned integer eights but
the kernel converts a subtraction into
plus of the first vector minus the
second vector it converts this into a
plus and a minus and minus of an
unsigned integer unsigned integer type
is not a good thing we'd have to use
some kind of you know we'd have to
decide if is that an error or not or is
that allowed we're allowed to do the
ones complement or whatever of the
unsigned representation whereas in the
compiler we can do that that that's
subtraction directly without any any of
these problems and similar kinds of
things if I want to do an expression
that's 1 plus 2 times n a to the power
of 2 these are all machine integer twos
or Machine integer numbers whereas in
the compiler I can mark these up as a
definite type that matches this so this
is some this is a way to do that say
that I have an expression if X is less
than 0 I can type mark up this 0 to be
the same type as the original input and
so everything in this computation
matches this this type of the inputs and
I'm working a fixed fixed type domain
there yeah so what would it look like so
we haven't hooked this up yet but what
would it look like so this is the
compilers specification when it works
with a vector packed array of this type
so it would look like this exactly the
same this is packed array this now
becomes the America ray except we're
allowed to use a different you know
different types in order to do the
arithmetic so in order to avoid at least
in the first version of several versions
however may it's going to be all of
these complicated problems in the kernel
exposing all the arithmetic on these
numeric arrays the first thing that
we'll do is is have them to work through
the compiler
with a much more uniform sort of
environment so just to conclude the
America is an extension of packed array
and it included included machine
arithmetic types the packed array data
structure has actually been unified with
the numeric array data structures they
all use exactly the same code now so
we've eliminated the factory code and
make it a subset of the numeric array
code then we can focus on optimizing
just one implementation all the
arithmetic and the structural operations
are performed in Wolfram rtl so some of
them being moved there from the kernel
and some of them are being rewritten
inside the RTL we use openmp for
paralyzation if you're just a casual use
of packed arrays and you don't care
anything about the compiler or anything
else or numeric array or anything else
because they're now the same code base
everything that you've done before that
uses packed arrays will now work faster
irrespective of everything else so as I
said before the reasons to do this in a
separate library that's linked into
Mathematica is because we can use a more
modern code base so this is just a bit
of history of the Wolfram aarti all IB
this is when we started working on
packed arrays and then exported this
library for external C code and then
this is when we started working on the
new compiler and you can see sort of the
development that's gone on and this the
number of files that we've we've sort of
been adding over time and the code base
is growing but it's not growing too much
because as we go and remove lots of C
code often the C++ code is much more
compact so I've written something like
two hundred and fifty thousand lines of
code but I've removed two hundred
thousand so yeah that's pretty much
sorry that's it that's everything thank
you very much
you